Der Sound der Alpen: Jauchzen und Jodeln
haben hier Tradition.
Für Erika Stucky ist der Jodler vor allem eins:
ein Ausruf von Lebenslust.
Erika Stucky ist seit vielen Jahren
eine bekannte Jodel-Künstlerin
in der Schweizer Musikszene.
Das Echo der Alpen ist ihre Inspiration.
Das Eis des Aletschgebiets hat
Erika Stucky unzählige Male bestiegen.
Um den größten Gletscher
der Schweiz ranken sich Mythen,
es sind die Geistergeschichten ihrer Kindheit.
Geboren wurde Erika Stucky in den USA
in den 1960er-Jahren.
Dass ihre Eltern später beschlossen,
in ein kleines Schweizer Bergdorf zu ziehen,
war ein Schock für sie.
Zwei Wurzeln, doppelte Heimat: Aus diesem
Kultur-Mix entsteht Erika Stuckys Musik.
Auf der Bühne hat sie viele Rollen:
moderne Heidi, freches Cowgirl.
Jodeln mischt sie nicht nur mit
Rock ’n’ Roll, [sondern] auch mit Blues.
Klagelied, Warnung oder
Lockruf für das Vieh:
Mit einem Jodler kommunizierten früher
die Bergleute von einer Alm zur anderen.
Erika Stucky interpretiert den
traditionellen Volksbrauch ganz modern.
Schweizer und US-amerikanischer
Heimatsound: die Jodlerin Erika Stucky.